[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
i said oh damn i've been shot but i'm
not conscious
a texas man survives a shooting then
learns the suspect is being called a
serial killer
his story of survival plus an ohio man
gets a plea deal for murder then turns
around and implicates his ex-wife
but is he telling the truth he's going
to pay for by spending the rest of his
life in prison
and the state supreme court is reviewing
bill cosby's conviction
how his victims feel about his possible
release he has consistently said he
feels no remorse
later a potential bribery for a
presidential pardon scheme revealed
our investigative coverage law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to lawn crime daily i'm
brian buckmart along with terry austin
a texas man was shot by a supposed
serial killer and lived to tell the
story
law and crime daily's angenette levy
spoke with the victim and had his
incredible tale
you know brian it is nothing short of a
miracle that marshall boyd
survived this shooting his girlfriend
was actually sitting right next to him
in the car when the shooting happened
and she escaped without a scratch
when i got shot it was like i was
floating in the deepest darkest water
marshall boyd is home from the hospital
after surviving a hail of bullets fired
at his car
when this gentleman pulled back up next
to us he had his
he had his window down and that's when
he started firing
and uh well the first i don't know first
shot hit me in the head
and so i don't know i can't tell you
much after that the bullets hit boyd in
the back
head and hand stephanie thomas ducked
and fortunately wasn't hit
he kept telling me call my kids tell
them i love them and i love you
and call my mom and i'm like you're
going to tell your kids you love them
don't talk like that just stay with me
stay with me boyd and thomas shared
these photos of the car
dallas police say 31-year-old jeremy
harris fired
16 times he's also charged with killing
the father of his ex-girlfriend
and three people in dallas that he
didn't know police say two other people
survived being shot
in my opinion based on what i've seen so
far
i believe that this is the definition of
a serial killer
it's random there is no known
association between victims
police had released surveillance video
and a screen shot of a black chevy tahoe
used in the shootings
boyd says harris was driving a black suv
when he was shot
he's grateful to be alive when i found
out that
nobody had survived an encounter with
this guy yet
i was even more emotional about it all
it's been it's been an emotional thing
dallas police actually said that jeremy
harris has a minor
criminal history things like theft and
drug charges even domestic violence but
nothing like murder or robbery marshall
boyd's sister has set up a fundraising
page on facebook to help
with his medical bills and the cost of
replacing things on that vehicle
brian wow and uh and jeanette has he
said if he plans to testify if harris
goes to trial
yeah actually um they've been told both
stephanie thomas and marshall boyd
they've been told
that they will be subpoenaed and will
likely testify they're really
some of the only living witnesses to
these crimes
and marshall boyd says he is eager to
testify
i'm gonna testify on his tomb i'll be
right there in that courtroom
i promise you that i'm not scared of him
one bit
he what he needs to be scared of is the
rest of his life in prison
jeremy harris remains in jail right now
he's being held on a three million
dollar bond
brian remarkable story thanks very much
and jeanette
and for legal analysis on the case terry
austin joins me
terry please have labeled the suspect a
serial killer but some of our viewers
say
it was more like he was on a killing
spree what are your take
you know i think it's really a
distinction without a difference whether
you call it a spree or a serial killing
i think the fact is there were multiple
deaths here
at different locations and you know what
they define as a serial killer is
someone who is actually
having a plan someone who's thinking
about it taking their time between
each killing so you know i i think it
could be called a serial killer
if it's really really random then maybe
you could call it a spree but i think
the bottom line is you know there were
multiple killings here
yeah it's interesting a lot of the fbi
literature and other
jurisdictions i've looked at doesn't
really describe what a serial killer is
just three or more killings with pauses
in between and it differentiates that
from a mass
murderer thank you very much for that
terry
now terry you've got an update on a case
that we've been following closely
i do i've just learned that a hearing
for one of the suspects of the so-called
doomsday cult couple
will have a hearing on a request for a
change of venue
lori valo and her husband chad dabell
are accused of covering up the deaths of
valo's two children
j.j valo and tyler ryan neither are
charged with murder
but the children's bodies were
discovered on daebel idaho
property a judge ruled the couple must
go
to trial together but dave bell's
attorney is requesting it be moved to a
different district
dave bell's attorneys say it will be
impossible to find an impartial jury in
fremont
or its surrounding counties all right
that's a kind of an interesting argument
but terry that's not all
dave bell's defense is requesting right
that's right they are requesting this
change of venue as we mentioned and
they're also
requesting a motion to dismiss citing
insufficient evidence
which is incredible when you think about
it because
the charge is the destruction of
evidence and the bodies were actually
found in his property so i think that
motion
is clearly not going to prevail yeah and
of course we we know as both of us being
lawyers uh
you've got to file the motions you got
to put them through but as you look at
some of these motions
do you think that any of them have a
chance of being successful
well you know it's very interesting i do
think there's a slight possibility
that the change of venue motion could
succeed but you know whether it's in
fremont or whether
it's in madison county everyone in idaho
and in fact everyone in the world knows
about this case
so i think changing the venue is not
going to make a difference and i think
that the defense will lose probably both
motions yeah we'll see how that plays
out and of course we'll give you guys
the updates as that plays out
still ahead on law and crime daily
should bill cosby's conviction be
overturned
we break down the appellate arguments
but first the attorney for a man who
pled guilty to murder tries to explain
why his client is pointing the finger at
someone else that's after the break
[Music]
welcome back an ohio woman is facing
life in prison for the murder of her
ex-husband's former girlfriend
a jury convicted erica stefanko of
murdering army veteran ashley biggs
her ex chad cobb testified that stefanko
placed a fake pizza order to lure biggs
a delivery driver to her death cobb pled
guilty in a deal that took the death
penalty
off the table after stefanko divorced
him and married him
for his friend slash boss he implicated
her in the murder
the law on crime network spoke to cobb's
former attorney and asked him if he
could explain
why cobb denied strangling biggs with a
zip tie during stefanko's trial
well no it's the short answer
you know the physical evidence was
pretty overwhelming
i was surprised by that testimony i
really don't want to speculate on on
chad's
motives i can tell you based on what i
had seen at the trial
that it was clear that there was some
difficulties between
chad and his ex-wife i don't think it's
any secret and it came out
that erica ended up marrying chad's best
friend
i don't think it's any secret it came
out during the trial that there was some
custody
issues between cindy cobb chad's mom and
his parents and her ability to see
and have access to her grandkids i i
think that certainly didn't
help erica's motive to um
not get detected and i think that had
some play
in chad ultimately coming forward and
agreeing to testify
but inconsistencies did pop up in cobb's
testimony under oath
so we went back to cobb's former
attorney and asked him if he if he
should believe sorry if we should
believe cobb's latest story
i mean i believe based on my view of the
evidence that chad cobb was telling the
truth
there were certainly some some
discrepancies how major how minor those
discrepancies were i guess it's up to
the jury to decide i think they felt
that chad
was telling the truth and obviously felt
that his testimony was credible enough
to convict
erica of these very serious offenses
now remember a key piece of evidence was
a secret recording
cobb's mother made of erica stefanko
confessing to her involvement
so why did cindy cobb hold on to the
recording for four years
what i found cindy cobb to be was a very
loving mother who was deeply concerned
about her son as you can tell during her
testimony she wasn't making excuses for
him
she knew he had to be held accountable
for his role in this
and i also found cindy cobb to be a very
involved and very concerned grandmother
she would do anything for those kids and
the idea that
erica was going to try to keep them away
from her
is a huge motivating factor in my belief
causing cindy to take some action and
and do what she could to be with her
grandkids
terry what do you make about a defense
attorney speaking about their client
like this keep in mind this is the same
attorney who arranged a plea deal for
chad cobb
to spare him from the death penalty in
this case
well you know i think he cannot ignore
the fact that
chad's testimony was very inconsistent
not just a little bit inconsistent he's
talking about
details but they were huge issues i mean
one that he pled to actually
killing biggs and now he's saying he had
nothing to do with it
and that erica stefanko had everything
to do with it so
i don't think he can actually say that
these were minor inconsistencies
agreed now cindy cobb's explanation for
holding on to the recordings or even
making them for that matter does that
make sense in your books
yeah well you know here's what i think
she made those recordings and she was
saving them for a rainy day and the
rainy day
was the fact that she could not see her
grandchildren the way she wanted to
and so she decided to use this recording
at a time when she could use it against
stephanie or erica stefanco so yeah i
think that it was very calculated
on uh cindy cobb's part and i think as a
mother
she clearly was doing everything she
could to
help her son as far as uh you know
implicating somebody else is concerned
yeah and i get it some people might
perceive that to be a little shady a
little underhanded especially in terms
of the timing
but at the end of the day erica stefanco
spoke on a recorded
tape even though she didn't know it and
the jury heard it and considered it
terry thanks a lot for uh the update on
that case
coming up on law on crime daily possible
bribes for presidential pardons our
report investigates
plus will convicted comedian bill cosby
be successful in his legal bid to
overturn
his guilty verdict or legal analysis
after the break
it's up to the pennsylvania state
supreme court they'll decide if
disgraced committee and bill cosby's
conviction
should be overturned cosby was convicted
at his second trial in 2018
of sexually assaulting andrea constand
in 2004.
his attorneys are arguing that five
women should not have been allowed
to testify about uncharged bad acts
basically
claims that cosby assaulted them too
attorney gloria allred represents 33
accusers
three of them testified at trial and she
says their testimony should stand
by showing the testimony allowing the
testimony of prior bad act witnesses it
shows that
mr cosby was not mistaken about whether
andrea consented because look look at
the
testimony of the prior bad act witnesses
uh if he is
drugging on and sexually assaulting
other women he knows that if a woman is
incapacitated by
alcohol or drugs she can't consent he's
not mistaken about it
he's doing it so that they can't reject
him in other words not consent or
consent
they're incapacitated and that is why
they wanted to show it that and of
course
because they want to improve a common
plan scheme or design that mr cosby had
now terry the judges were really
pressing the prosecutors about why they
needed these additional witnesses
some agreed there was prejudice what do
you think of the judges asking
why the the prosecutors needed these
additional witnesses
you know i listened to the judge's
questions and the fact is
sometimes judges ask all of these
questions and it seems as though
they are leaning in one direction when
in fact they're leaning in the other
direction so
i don't know at the end of the day what
the result will be but i think as far as
these
other witnesses the prior bad act
witnesses are concerned
that it makes sense to allow some of
those witnesses maybe not 33
maybe not one but maybe five so i i
think at the end of the day we may see
that that particular issue is going to
stand and that there won't be
any reversal as as far as that issue is
concerned
agreed now terry one of the strongest
arguments the attorney
beaujon had was that proof of prejudice
was
obvious because there was no conviction
when only one
bad act witness testified in the first
trial what did you make of that argument
you know actually brian it's an
excellent argument because
you know when there's only one witness
and there's no conviction and then
ultimately you see when they're five it
is sort of at the end of the day the
results
showing that there might have been some
prejudice as far as that was concerned
so
i think it was a good argument but
whether or not that argument prevails i
think we'll see
yeah no terry my struggle with this is
that
cosby's attorneys may be right but only
because i think the law has never really
contemplated
one person having so many bad act
witnesses i mean 33
should the system change to accommodate
these unique circumstances or what are
your thoughts
you know what's sad here brian is that
we have cases like
epstein weinstein here cosby where there
are
so many bad acts prior bad acts
and maybe the law does need to be
changed so that we can see
some more of that evidence as far as
these defendants are concerned if in
fact
it has to do not with their propensity
to commit a specific
act but obviously it has to do with
their
scheme and their opportunity and their
plan so maybe the law should be changed
but absolutely
we have too many of these to think about
now of course if this case does get
overturned the prosecution can come
forward with the same charges
and retry the case again like they did
the first time thank you terry now when
we come back
a federal judge unseals an explosive
report where senior white house
officials part of a bribery for pardon
scheme
what documents reveal next
are people paying for presidential
pardons well
recently unsealed federal documents
claim unregistered lobbyists tried to do
just that
long crime senior investigative reporter
adam classfield is here with a bombshell
report adam hi
well the as you said these this was
a bombshell uh court order that was
unsealed yesterday from an investigation
that we know has been ongoing since at
least
august the order
basically showed that
federal prosecutors had been looking
into what they called a
bribery for pardon scheme and also
a a secret lobbying scheme
now the secret lobbying scheme tried to
apply uh
senior white house officials according
to
the court papers and that essentially
the uh government has been trying to get
information about this
and they went to court to try to defeat
attorney
client privilege the judge allowed it
and that investigation
when she allowed it chief district judge
beryl howell basically gave a 90-day
window
and said at the end of these 90 days you
have to tell me
what we can release publicly and so
we're finding out about it now
all right so you said a few things that
kind of caught my ear
you said it happened since august uh
but why are we finding out about just
now and do we know who unsealed these
documents
well the judge basically gave that 90
day window and she told the government
at the end of these 90 days let me know
what i can release publicly now
interestingly the department of justice
tried not to release
anything and they recommended to keep it
entirely under wraps
judge howell rejected that
and so essentially by overruling them
she gave us a little bit of a public
window of
an investigation that has been long
brewing now for most attorneys listening
to this when you
hear when you hear they broke
attorney-client privilege like
if my client kills someone as a public
defender and they
die even after they're dead i'm not
legally allowed to break attorney-client
privilege that's pretty strong are there
any indications that something
really really bad happened to break that
attorney-client privilege
in this situation there were a couple of
grounds in which
the judge allowed this evidence hunt to
go forward
one was the crime fraud exception and
another was simply that the person who
was
entrusted with the documents that the
government was trying to get was
not in fact an attorney so that's part
of the reason why the government got the
green light on this
and we are likely to get more
transparency because
the judge basically uh kept an
a schedule and saying that in the future
uh let's bring more sunlight to it so
people are looking into the details that
were released and those details are
explosive
and we are likely to learn more as this
goes ahead
all right so quickly it's a two-part
scheme can you just tell us what the two
parts are
in this scheme they're saying happened
absolutely
well the they are divided into a secret
lobbying scheme
and a bribery for pardon scheme
those are direct quotes and
interestingly enough what the court said
is that these were
related schemes so the scheme
for lobbyists without any disclosure to
be
trying to ply senior white house
officials is related
to the bribery for pardon scheme that
involves a
tacit uh promise of a substantial
political donation that there was a
history of substantial political
donations
and they wanted clemency for their
client
all right i like it the best part about
that one is no
attorney-client privilege because some
of them wasn't actually an attorney
exactly that's a good one adam thanks so
much for the report we'll see you next
time
thank you very much for having me brian
yeah now terry these presidential
pardons only apply to federal charges so
even if the president
grants them that means these individuals
could still face state and local charges
right
yeah no question about it actually there
are more federal charges too but we
won't even get into that
but as far as the state charges are
concerned their charges as far as the
family business is concerned
charges for insurance fraud there's in
new york criminal tax evasion we've been
trying to get his tax returns
federal bank fraud charges so there are
lots of charges against him on a
statewide basis particularly in new york
all right thanks terry and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you